let's talk about how serious it gets we
have this uh this story here from the
national review the new york times
suddenly discovers hunter biden laptop
and corruption investigations are real
this is this is amazing yeah hunter
biden is being investigated for crimes
and uh the reporting is uh that he he
paid off he took a loan out i guess to
pay off his tax burden hoping they
wouldn't indict him but apparently the
feds don't care because they're like if
you falsify your taxes you're in trouble
paying it off later doesn't change
anything or how about illegally
registered get a handgun rather
you know what's funny about that is the
double standard so if it wasn't familiar
hunter biden what did he do he he lied
on his uh
absolutely yeah he lied on it saying he
wasn't doing he didn't do drugs
definitely did drugs right and a lot of
them yeah but it's on video everywhere
yeah here's the challenge right the
first challenge is the double standard
we all agree that's a problem you don't
get to come out and say we got to follow
these rules and then the president's kid
gets to break all the rules the second
thing is however i don't think i think
it's it's it's burdensome to get a
firearm in the first place and so maybe
there's an argument about a simple
background check that doesn't even take
that long but if you have a right to
keep and bear arms then we got to talk
about what the constitution means and
what the limits are so i'm i'm always
wary to to you know come out and be like
oh he had a gun the wrong way and i'm
like well you know
if he was doing drugs that i get now
you're a criminal and you're due process
through due process you do lose certain
rights that's right that's true but i
also want to make sure we keep the door
open to say like
i'm i'm a big fan of nationwide
constitutional carry so there there was
a bumper sticker came out in the in
texas i don't know about up here back
probably in the 60s or 70s and it said
when guns are outlawed only outlaws will
have guns
it's just that simple the criminals and
the thugs and ronald reagan said it he
said the best way to get gun control is
to lock up the criminals and thugs that
have been convicted of a gun crime put
them in behind the jail and then throw
if you don't throw away the key at least
lose it for a long time
well here we go
we now have the new york times
openly admitting
that uh let me read a little bit here
they say if you are really industrious
you can dig 20 pages into the a section
of today's new york times and find a 1
700 word news story by three of its top
reporters relating that the justice
department's investigation of president
biden's son hunter is not merely a tax
matter turns out that prosecutors are
probing his penchant for cashing in on
his father's political influence through
payments by overseas entities for which
he did not register as a foreign agent
well even better if you weighed 23
paragraphs into the story you will learn
that prosecutors are examining emails
between biden and his business
associates that come from a cachet of
files that appeared that appears to have
come from a laptop abandoned by mr
hunter biden in a delaware repair shop
you don't say
this is the story that the new york uh
the new york times had said was you know
russian disinformation cnn uh maybe not
the new york times because i want to
misquote them but i know several
reporters were saying it was this
information it was questionable
spiderman himself said it was russian
defense right
jen sackey
according to these intel sources
politico it was natasha bertrand she was
with politico and now cnn put out this
story which was a fabrication because uh
i love this glenn greenwald's reporting
he said even in the story where she said
intel sources say it was disinfo the
intel sources said we are not saying
it's disinformation we're saying we
don't trust the information so this lie
comes out now the big issue is the media
lies to us
not every single entity i mean the new
york post they published this they were
getting us that information big tech
colludes with the media and now because
of this there's a few interesting polls
media research center and rasmussen
found i believe it was rasmussen that if
uh regular people if you're voting if
american voters were aware of this story
around six to i think 17 percent would
not have voted for biden they doesn't
mean they're voting for trump but that
would have had a big impact on the
election absolutely yeah now think about
the war in ukraine
with russia invading and ukraine saying
we want these big fighter jets we want
nato support and who's the president a
guy with corrupt business dealings
through his son in this very country and
that has me worried these are the
ramifications of media lying to us yeah
absolutely so 45 percent of biden voters
said they did not know about hunter
biden's deals and 9.5 said as you
mentioned they would not have voted for
him had they known and now the new york
times is coming out and saying hey
remember that thing we called you crazy
conspiracy theorists for believing well
put a dollar in the jar because a couple
months later you're allowed to believe
that thing
yeah and that's exactly what we saw all
the time we in our district i'm a very
conservative district we you know i took
ron paul's place in congress
oh yeah very conservative district on
the gulf coast and and we get they
choose to fill yeah i was going to say
that is a tough spot to be in big shoes
quite an honor well thank you you betcha
and i had this endorsement when i ran
along with governor rick perry and then
attorney general
greg abbott and ted cruz and i can go
right down the list because they know
how conservative i am
but we put all their information out in
our district making that point and our
the jefferson county in our district was
the only swing county out of 254
counties in texas
we're turning them red they were
democrat a lot of salt to the earth
people fishermen welders electricians a
lot of refineries and stuff on the coast
and the jefferson county voted for obama
in 08 reelection in 12 and in 2016 they
went for trump wow so they got it down
in our district we wish we could
duplicate that replicate that you know
across the country you bet they knew
that but they purposely put it out
they
wanted to
suppress the story right before the
election that's when it came out like
that's when it was project veritas that
dropped it no no it's near post it was
an aircraft new york who dropped the
story i mean who put out the story
though that it was that we found hunter
biden's life new york post it was i'm
pretty sure the new york post was the
first to publish the story yeah that's
why they got taken off twitter yeah and
they got you you couldn't even
remember
you couldn't message a friend the link
that's right twitter was blocking it i
remember that talk about evil people
authoritarians
oligarchs whatever you want to call it
so my question is you know over the past
several months i've just been saying at
a certain point with all the lies you
know justice from let now free men
believe how how about that we get more
we get stories every single year some
big news cycles some big protests and it
turns out to be a lie or manipulation
and i'm just thinking how do we just
finally say to the likes of cnn and the
new york times or whatever you guys can
go play over there with your dwindling
audiences and we're going to keep the
truth here and have these conversations
somewhere else how do we how do we
create our own narratives right well one
thing one way was what you said earlier
hey look tell your friends about this
show right you know that's why share
share share you know you better hear
that everybody the congressman says
share the show
share share you bet well right now we're
chasing our tales though republican
messaging in general is still having to
respond to the national media the
mainstream media and instead of putting
our own content out we are here we are
again responding to fake news stories
over and over again rather than
highlighting what we should be doing and
what's wrong i want to that's what the
narrative is and what should and what
should we be focusing on yeah sure are
you guys familiar with the defiant l's
huh you see defiant l's on on twitter
and instagram
it's great uh define else takes uh two
tweets and uh places them together for
comedic effect the first tweet we have
here is from jen saki who says hunter
biden's story is russian disinfo dozens
of former intel officials say they
didn't that wasn't true and then below
it is the new york post hunter biden's
infamous laptop confirmed in new york
times report
it's a scary prospect oh you can't make
this stuff up well i mean they can yeah
yeah the scary thing i suppose is we
laugh
at being right and we laugh at the
absurdity but look at gas prices look at
inflation look at the afghanistan
withdrawal look at what's going on in
eastern europe the this these lies and
this manipulation is burning our country
to the ground now the thing is the left
the antifa when they get tricked they
scream until their vocal cords shred and
they smash windows and start fires right
we point out the lies and start laughing
and saying ha ha we were right the whole
time there's there's this vile rage that
is being wielded through the
manipulation the media that does give
them power
and it's causing problems and harm to
this country well that's all the
attention is aimed toward them and then
they say you know what can we these poor
people they need
they don't need more police they need
social uh social workers yeah and i'm
like oh my gosh you can't make this up
what did reagan say lock up the thugs
and the criminals and throw away the key
yeah a little much for me i'm a bit
libertarian in in you know in a lot of
these rega uh respects but i think the
issue is we're seeing uh the other side
of that extreme extremism from the
progressives in places like new york
where they let all the criminals out oh
sure and then you get there was one guy
who was a like a 40 time repeat offender
who was laughing being like y'all locked
me up the first time he just let me go
and it's like he's going to keep doing
it so there's a real challenge i think
the big challenge is with big cities
though i i really am not a big fan of
cities i grew up in cities lived in them
until only the past few years i think
you know i come out here to the middle
of nowhere everything's much more
relaxed it just absol you're more likely
to know who your local uh deputies are
sure you go and meet him you talk to him
you elect your law enforcement you go to
these big cities and it's just faceless
law enforcement faceless judges nobody
talks to their neighbor and that leads
to the kind of authoritarianism it leads
to the police brutality the left is
complaining about all the time yeah well
let me brag on texas for a minute
because where i'm from we know all of
our elected officials and i live in a a
district of course we're about uh not
quite 900 000 people now with the
redistricting and in my county one of
the biggest cities is league city it's
about 110 000 and then beaumont's about
a hundred thousand and so there's big
cities around right and we know all of
our elected officials in texas we're so
pro
law enforcement pro-life and and pro-gun
you can go right down the list we know
and they know us too and they know they
can depend on us and we can depend on
them probably not so much in the
northeast chicago west the left coast as
i call it some of the others yeah this
is so i i think one thing that's really
important in the in the discussion about
police is that new york is very very
different from you know beaumont for
instance absolutely so people in new
york when they're saying to fund the
police or whatever they're talking about
a bunch of different problems
my response to a lot of these uh you
know blue city uh urban police
departments is they were locking down
people for covid violin their
constitutional rights shutting down
churches so i'm like by all means get
rid of them why well these are democrat
voters and democrat cities who voted in
democrats who appointed these cops the
cops shut down churches now they want to
get rid of them i'm like good get rid of
them do you think i say let it happen
look at what's happening in seattle
right now
let them let them destroy themselves
you see all these like murder rates
going up and crime and serial killer in
new york but even in amazon's moving
their their one of their main
headquarters out of seattle because of
all the violence that's been happening
with on the street and so the people
that are that are in that city have to
look around and say this is what we get
for saying defund the police this is
what we get for these little let them
destroy themselves you know in texas i
wasn't there this time because i was in
congress but they passed a bill this
last time for about sanctuary cities and
said look if you're a sanctuary city in
texas and you don't believe in enforcing
immigration law and all those things
you don't get any state funding
you want to defund your police and be a
sanctuary city and you want state
funding nope if you're a sanctuary city
you get zero funding austin was one of
the ones who cut the police i think i
was going to say they just pointed the
finger at austin right you know the
people's republic of austin
and and i think they defunded it's like
100 or 110 million i forget the exact
amount and so greg abbott and company
got in gear and they said that's fine
you want to defund the police well we'll
just you get no more state money and by
golly do you know that one very short
order i don't know a month or two later
that austin came back and put 110
million whatever dollars was back in the
budget for the police this this all this
kind of stuff
you know freaks me out because you've
got people from california moving to
austin moving to texas
and what they don't understand i had a
we had a ton of people telling us you
guys should move to austin and we're
like we're gonna go to west virginia or
at least the west virginia area for the
most part and the thing about texas is
when when joe rogan for instance you
know he's a good dude when he moves to
austin
it's because he thinks california's
going crazy and you can you can
reasonably talk to him and say you're
not going to support those kind of
policies are you and he'll tell you you
know he's like oh i i wouldn't i
wouldn't do that i'm not going to move
to an area
but support staff
what happens when elon musk you know he
moves to texas right he's going to bring
his factory those employees are going to
move with them these are california
residents they're going to vote blue and
he's going to bring them all into texas
and he's going to start
bringing in democrats into texas so that
that freaks me out
it's concern for us too and of course
you know it's free country you can cross
state lines but what we want to do is
make sure the californians have to apply
for a passport right and a visa to come
visit texas and we laugh about it but it
really is true and there's talk about in
from the texas delegation up here that
there's been reported signs in
california that says the last one out of
california turn off the lights wow so
the amount of people coming to texas
1300
people a day right not all not all from
california yeah dfw every three minutes
gets a new resident wow every three
minutes every three
florida
minutes
texas i think are seeing the largest
population increases right now i i will
say and maybe i'm being a little naive
here but i just want to try to throw
some optimism in there are a lot of
conservative people in california who
just don't vote in any of their
elections because they see their state
as hopelessly blue and i hope that those
are the kinds of people moving off to
texas and so you're going to have an
influx of red voters as well but
obviously the blue voters coming in and
trying to change the face of the
political scene there is a huge problem
yeah it is shameless and we're not
unaware of that there's actually a group
that's out there registering voters
we go back and we look at california i
know the ones you talk about that don't
vote you know they're not going to be on
record
but we're going back and you know you
can't find out how somebody voted but
you can find out if they voted and if
they voted in republican primary they
identify as republican democrat
libertarian green or whatever
or independent and the group is busy
working right now identifying those
republican voters and when they come to
texas they're sending them a letter in
the mail with a are you registering to
vote you know here's your chance you'll
register to vote that's amazing good for
you guys are you familiar with scott
pressler
know the name why do i know that he's
probably the most famous voter
registration activists right now
yeah there's memes about them because
it's uh you know you'll see a tweet from
someone where they're like i'm just sick
of the city i moved to texas then he
responds right away have you registered
to vote at your current address so
there's a meme where it's like a dog
answers the phone and the dog's like
hello and he's like hey this is god
pressler have you registered to vote
because yeah but uh he's doing he's done
amazing work in um i think his work has
led to what like the republican party in
florida becoming bigger than the
democratic party something like that
yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there